قالت هيئه عمليات التجاره البحريه
البريطانيه انها طلقت تقريرا عن حادث وقع
على بعد 55 ميلا بحريا جنوب غربي ميناء
الحديده اليمني وذكرت هيئه عمليات التجاره
البحريه البريطانيه انه لم يتم الابلاغ عن
اي ضرر بالسفينه او طاقمها لكن قائد
السفينه ابلغ عن رؤيه عده انفجارات في
محيط مدينه
الحديده نقلت وكاله رايترز عن القياده
الامريكيه الوسطى ان سفينه الحاويات ميرسك
تحدثت عن تعرضها لهجوم صاروخي خلال عبورها
البحر الاحمر واشارت القياده الى ان
الباخره ترفع علم سنغفوره وتملكها وتديرها
الدنمارك وطلبت المساعده وهبت مدمره
امريكيه لنجدتها وقال بيان القياده انه لا
انباء عن اصابات جراء التصدي لهجوم استهدف
المركب اثناء ع جنوب البحر الاحمر ونسب
رويترز الى القياده الامريكيه الوسطى
القول ان مدمره امريكيه اسقطت صاروخين
اطلقا من مناطق سيطره الحوثيين في
اليمن